the united states under the orders of
president joe biden has executed a
strike which killed al-qaeda leader
ayman al-zawahiri who worked closely
with osama bin laden
in the 9 11 attacks and naturally right
wingers are desperately trying to
downplay
and dismiss this event which were it
under a republican president
they would be demanding that the
president be enshrined in some kind of
gold-plated statue that's what they
would be doing if it were trump who had
announced this and it's an incredible
contrast that we've seen over the last
24 36 72 hours where on the one hand the
biden administration strikes a 911
terrorist a major person on the global
wanted list and on the other hand donald
trump quite literally downplays
taking saudi money
in this golf tournament that was played
an event being played at bedminster his
golf course and says bizarrely nobody's
gotten to the bottom of 9 11.
think about that in the same weekend in
the same three four day period former
president donald trump um kowtowing to
the conspiracy theorists with nobody's
gotten to the bottom of 9 11 whereas on
the other hand joe biden authorizes a
strike that kills one of the major
actors
in those 9 11 attacks now before we get
into
the right wingers falling all over
themselves to criticize joe biden i
think it's important to mention that any
serious progressive who respects the
rule of law and due process and all of
the stuff that the right claims to
respect but actually doesn't
reasonable progressives can be generally
concerned about
what is exactly the legal infrastructure
for when the u.s strikes these
individuals in other countries they
aren't getting due process that's
absolutely true
and while i on a personal level
have no doubt whatsoever based on
everything that we've seen and read
about ayman al-zawahiri that this guy
was guilty
that is my personal opinion and he
didn't get due process and of course you
can argue well this this is technically
part of a wartime situation that dates
all the way back well but that's
complicated too so i'm not downplaying
that at all
that's not why the right wingers are
angry that's not at all why the right
winger is ranked so let's first start
with the announcement from joe biden
make it clear again tonight
that no matter how long it takes
no matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people the
united states will find you and take you
out
after relentlessly seeking zawahiri for
years under presidents bush obama and
trump our intelligence community located
zawahiri earlier this year
he had moved to downtown kabul to
reunite with members of his immediate
family
after carefully considering
the clear and convincing evidence of his
location
i authorized a precision strike that
would remove him from the battlefield
once and for all
this mission was carefully planned
rigorously minimize the risk of harm to
other civilians
and one week ago after being advised the
conditions were optimal
i gave the final approval to go get him
and the mission was a success
none of his family members were hurt and
there were no civilian casualties okay
so that's the announcement from joe
biden you would think that the right
would rally around this what a patriotic
big boy that joe biden did but no here
is tucker carlson saying you know
biden's bragging about killing this
al-qaeda leader i don't feel any safer
give a speech boasting that he's killed
an al qaeda figure in afghanistan great
feel safer of course you don't
nobody does and the reason nobody feels
safer is that tucker carlson is friends
with donald trump is biden's response to
the disaster in afghanistan oh rather
than pause and learn from it maybe fire
the people responsible for it not simply
the self-destructive withdrawal from
afghanistan but also the pointless
20-year war there rather than do any of
that like a normal person would do
biden immediately set off in another
direction provoking yet another conflict
this one in eastern europe so look at
this uh biden authorizes a strike that
kills a 911 leader and tucker says i
don't feel any safer because of biden's
withdrawal from afghanistan which is
identical to what trump's withdrawal
from afghanistan would have been
and he blames biden for provoking
russia's invasion of ukraine
reeks of desperation senate minority
leader kevin mccarthy posting to twitter
we owe a debt of gratitude to the brave
americans who took out the terrorist
al-zawahiri the biden administration
must provide congress with a briefing as
soon as possible to discuss the
resurgence of al qaeda in the region
following his disastrous withdrawal from
afghanistan so by uh biden not getting
any of the credit from mccarthy trump of
course would have had mccarthy praying
at an altar to him and then newsmax
taking the dementia approach and the
covet approach
saying well okay instead of talking
about the substance of this terrorist
being killed
newsmax cuts in and says biden seems
confused and sick
now
justice has been delivered and this
terrorist leader is no more people
around the world no longer need to fear
the vicious and determined killer
the united states continues to
demonstrate our resolve and our capacity
to defend the american people against
those who seek to do us harm all right
so we told you we'd jump in and show you
some of this the president at the white
house big speech he's got covet again he
got the recurring case uh the rebound
case i guess uh but uh they brought him
out and they gave him the teleprompter
doesn't seem too familiar with the
speech
seems a bit uh a bit off base but maybe
he's still sick let's go now to chief
white house correspondent now that's
actually kind of funny how they dismiss
the entire substance and instead go with
like oh biden has coveted again if this
were donald trump newsmax would be do 24
hours of coverage with trump uh you know
looking victorious and as alpha as trump
can possibly look so immediately
downplaying all of it reasonable
concerns for progressives about all of
these types of killings but the right
just desperate desperate not to give
biden any kind of win
even by their standards is the important
point that i would make
monkey pox is unfortunately exploding
new york city has declared a state of
emergency and the right continues to
repeat homophobic tropes to try to
dismiss
this one also i mean listen
they'll dis
any public health concern
they will dismiss uh if possible with
whatever justification they can find
with covid it was it's the china virus
and it's not really dangerous and the
masks don't work and they want to take
our freedoms or whatever with monkey pox
it's basically
it's a gay disease it's a gay sexually
transmitted disease this is what they're
going with because it appears as though
the very early handful of cases
were in gay men and of course it has
gone well beyond that now and it's quite
frankly an incredibly irresponsible
distraction to be focusing on that but
we will get to that so a bunch of
different things going on daily beast
report it may be too late to stop monkey
pox becoming endemic in the u.s and
europe
we failed to get on top of the monkey
pox outbreak and we may have missed the
chance to stop the disease becoming
endemic and a permanent threat in the
u.s and europe monkey pox is spreading
fast all over the world especially in
the united states and europe with cases
doubling every two weeks there's a
growing risk that monkey pox will become
a permanent problem in countries where
before outbreaks were rare and small the
pox is in other words close to becoming
endemic in a lot of new places if this
happens it might become very difficult
to eradicate
monkey pox causes a fever and rash is
fatal in a small number of cases will
become yet another disease that people
have to worry about all the time there
are two paths to endemicity if the virus
infects enough people fast enough to
outpace efforts to trace transmission
and vaccinate it could become endemic in
people
the good news is that this kind of
endemicity doesn't have to be permanent
it's hard but possible to reverse it but
monkey pox was originally a zoonotic
animal virus it circulates in rodent and
monkey species in western central africa
where outbreaks in humans are frequent
if the pox finds a new home in some
animal species in north america or
europe could be squirrels rats or
prairie dogs it will be all but
impossible to eradicate regionally
meanwhile new york city has declared a
monkey pox state of emergency mayor eric
adams has declared a state of emergency
due to monkey pox the city estimates 150
000 people
mostly men who have sex with other men
are at risk the city has more than 1200
reported cases about 25 percent of all
the cases in the u.s
and continues to see the numbers rise
in terms of the vaccines the city is
facing a shortage of monkey pox vaccines
with appointments filling up minutes
after they're released the city expects
to get 80 000
monkey pox vaccine doses in the coming
days now there are some like margaery
taylor green and others who are mocking
the entire thing calling it a scam
saying it is a sexually transmitted
disease that only threatens a specific
group of people she says laugh at it
mock it reject rejected of course monkey
pox is a threat to some people in our
population but we know what causes it
and and that's pretty much um
it's it's basically a sexually
transmitted disease
so it's not a threat to
to most of the population
and so it's not a global pandemic it's
really not and people just have to have
to laugh at it mock it and and reject it
this is exactly how uh covid to some
degree covet much more contagious became
what it did i mean remember matt gates
laughed at it early in the pandemic matt
gates put on this enormous gas mask and
went on the house floor and it was all a
big joke
and then we know how that all went and
if this is only a sexually transmitted
disease that affects gay men
why do kids now have it well it was only
a matter of time it was only a matter of
time it spreads through contact of all
kinds and if an adult who's infected
picks up their kid
their kid can end up with monkey pox so
this is a very serious situation
not a shock
that republicans are again laughing off
another public health concern
will they ever learn
find me on twitter at d pacman and let
me know we're going to take a very quick
break much more coming up today glad
you're with us
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
listen i don't know what other shows you
watch i don't know what other shows you
listen to but this program is a little
different from some of those others we
actually are primarily funded by our
audience now i know the right-wingers
love to email in and say oh it's george
soros that's funding you or it must be
the democratic party or whatever that is
very much not the case oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad well part of that is true the
bonus show is one of the perks of
membership i would love for you to sign
up at joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting 22
to get yourself a tidy little discount
off of membership
we have another one of these completely
kafka-esque moments in american politics
donald trump has endorsed eric in a
missouri republican senate primary
both of the top candidates are named
eric and both erics are taking credit
saying i have been endorsed by donald
trump it is an absolutely bizarre
bizarre situation and donald trump again
as the daily beast reports throwing the
race into chaos
with his eric
endorsement check this out donald there
were questions about whether donald
trump would or would not endorse anyone
in this race one of the eric's eric
greitens was very much lobbying for the
trump endorsement he's done some wacky
things including bizarre campaign ads
and so many different things the primary
is today
and last night
donald trump puts out the following
endorsement
there is a big election in the great
state of missouri by the way half the
words are capitalized just i'm not even
going to mention that as we go because
just half of the words are randomly
capitalized okay there is a big election
in the great state of missouri and we
must send a maga champion and true
warrior to the u.s senate someone who
will fight for border security election
integrity our military and great
veterans together with having a powerful
toughness on crime in the border we need
a person who will not back down to the
radical left lunatics who are destroying
our country
i trust the great people of missouri on
this one to make up their own minds much
as they did when they gave me landslide
victories in the 2016 and 2020 elections
and i am therefore proud to announce
that eric all caps eric has my complete
and
total endorsement
this is another
unbelievable
kafka-esque fiasco
both candidates are named eric he
doesn't say which eric he's endorsing
clearly trying to have it both ways no
matter which eric wins
trump can claim victory and the under
girding of this
is that maggo world the magats
are sort of divided on the race some of
them like eric greitens some of them
like eric schmidt some of them don't
know what's up and what's down and day
and night and they're just in a fog and
have absolutely no idea what's going on
whatsoever now earlier on there were
some anecdotal reports that trump was
planning on or intended to endorse eric
greitens but it genuinely doesn't appear
that that's the case now check this out
both of them both eric's
accepting the endorsement eric greitens
immediately posting
honored to have the support of president
trump we will maga
with this big picture that says
president trump endorses
eric greitens greitens also tweeting
quote i am honored to receive trump's
endorsement from the beginning i've been
the true maga champion
fighting against the rhino establishment
backing schmidt
president trump said it best when he
characterized schmidt's campaign as
great dishonesty in politics well i
guess then trump endorsed greitens right
well no not really schmidt also took
credit for the endorsement going to
twitter with red alarm emojis saying
endorsement president trump
i'm grateful for president trump's
endorsement as the only america first
candidate who has actually fought for
election integrity border security and
against the left's indoctrination of our
kids i'll take that fight to the senate
to save america they both sound like
unhinged maga lunatics using all of the
hallmarks of uh of that
random capitalization of non-proper
nouns in their tweets um
delusions of grandeur and general
confusion about how american politics
works they both sort of sound like
pretty good mega candidates so donald
trump it's really a cop-out initially it
seemed like trump was just confused like
trump intended to endorse one or the
other eric
and ended up accidentally not
it now is looking abundantly clear that
this is just another trump cop-out and
he'll call this a victory no matter what
whichever of the eric's ends up winning
trump's going to say i got another one
put another slash mark in my win column
hey this is really really funny
and also sort of sad
one of the things we've learned about
the
neo-reactionary republican party some
people call it trumpism some people call
it magga
some people
don't talk about it at all and i envy
those people quite frankly um one of the
things we've learned about them is
they will fall for just about any scam
that's presented to them by republicans
by donald trump by don jr by kimberly
gilfoyle whoever right okay they just
they fall for it you say hey we need
your money
because i gotta fix up my private plane
they'll donate if you say i need your
money because i'm going to
do ardets and we're going to recount and
sue and overturn the election and they
just start hemorrhaging money okay they
just start sending the money in
they are that dumb they are that
gullible
one of the things many of you have been
writing to me about recently
is that um you are on you know
republican mailing lists or trump
mailing lists whatever just to kind of
see what's going on and many of you have
written to me that you're getting
hammered with fundraising requests
signed by trump although some of them
aren't from trump's pac some of them are
from the republican senate committee or
the gop
the rnc whatever
and that sometimes they're so frequent
that it's multiple times per hour i've
gotten screenshots of text messages from
viewers showing me that like four times
in an hour they were getting text
messages uh signed by donald trump in
trump's voice asking for money now right
wing um
what to even call right winger charlie
kirk
thinks trumpists aren't dumb enough to
fall for the fundraising cringe now i
have to give it to charlie kirk and this
clip we're going to look at
kirk correctly identifies that there's
too many fundraising messages going out
he's completely correct about that
but the funny thing is he says
the our people aren't dumb enough to
fall for this no charlie they are dumb
enough to fall for it that's what we've
seen take a look at this do you get some
of these emails
from donald trump or from the nrsc i
need 20 right now by the way it's not
from trump it's from all the consultants
around him and i just i love trump i
defend trump and i just think the people
around him that are sending these emails
are doing such a disservice to donald
trump right
i mean it is a joke it is a mockery i
talk to grassroots people all the time
they say charlie why do i get all these
emails i mean i could show you my text
messages here it is an absolute
insult to our intelligence this is just
over a couple days
it's really not an insult to their
intelligence it's tailored to their
intelligence text messages
trump rally alert have you rsvp'd for
trump's rally in wisconsin no i live in
wisconsin arizona actually
how about this one
don jr my father just called and asked
about you friend he's activated you're
seven times impact for five minutes by
the way i know don and i know that this
stuff is not even being run by them
president so by the way and and notice
that charlie kirk because he doesn't
want to lose access charlie kirk knows
that this is this is
just horror it looks horrible but he
doesn't want to lose access to trump and
don jr and everybody so he insists like
they're not even aware of any of this
stuff so who is it that's doing who has
the authority to send stuff written in
trump and don jr's name trump will
deliver marks at a rager major rally
this next one these are like within five
minutes they're sending them non-stop
offer attached from office of president
trump mar-a-lago okay he's in bedminster
right now
this is your only chance to claim the
end of month seven times impact trump
alert now president trump needs your
support do you have his back 15 minutes
left by the way i've tried my best to
try to tell the trump team to stop
sending these stupid emails and no one
listens to me so i'm gonna have to do it
on the show right you are going to lose
your supporters if you keep on sending
out this unfiltered garbage how about
this one biden and camel are terrified
that you'll click this link camella
camela save america people are not this
dumb okay actually well we have to raise
as much money as we can then how you
treat your voters with respect right so
listen the only charlie kirk is
completely correct that this looks
absolutely terrible i mean it's humor
it's terri the number of these pathetic
emails we covered one where it's like
uh
win lunch with trump
and in the fine print it's like trump
will not be at the lunch
it's like they were going to send
lindsey graham or something like that it
was absurd
and a lot of us would say these are
insults to our intelligence but it seems
like a lot of the people that are that
are getting the the stuff
really are that this dumb that's the
reality and case in point you need look
only after the 2020 election they were
fundraising every 10 minutes for audits
and legal challenges and overturn and
all this stuff and you look down at the
fine print and it would say 50 60 75 i
think in one case percent of each dollar
donated
could actually would actually be used
to pay off trump's campaign debt or to
generally fund i don't remember if at
the time it was the save america pac or
whatever else and i i think it's also
possible that charlie kirk is playing
this as
this isn't effective this will alienate
voters
and it is too much and you know it's an
insult to people's intelligence
charlie kirk runs an organization that
also to some degree depends on donations
for many of the same people and it
wouldn't shock me if charlie kirk is
aware that the pie is being sliced into
so many pieces
that
the donations the turning point may also
uh be declining dramatically i mean even
the trumpist donations i don't know
what's going on with turning points
fundraising to be clear
but the trump donations go there's
trump's pac there's the rnc there's the
republican senate campaign committee and
all these different things all of these
mega people with their hands out for the
grift and it seems like they're all kind
of getting hurt and i would if a
republican is complaining about another
republican
the first thought that should occur to
you is
do they have a personal interest in this
are they personally being hurt by what
they're criticizing and when it comes to
charlie kirk and turning point usa
it's completely plausible that that's
what's going on we'll have this clip
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show make sure you're
following us there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with professor paul slovik
who teaches psychology at the university
of oregon and also as president of the
decision sciences research institute in
eugene oregon really great having you on
i appreciate your time
thank you david it's good to be with you
so
maybe to start with
we make decisions as humans about risk
reward all the time in our everyday
lives i think with many of the types of
decisions we make we have the feeling
that we're pretty good at assessing the
level of risk when we are undertaking
these decisions
generally speaking
are humans as good as we think at
assessing risk or or not
um
it depends
if we're in a situation that's uh
familiar to us that we've you know
experienced before and
and and learned from our mistakes
and our successes then i think we're
pretty pretty good if it's a novel
situation uh where the
stakes are high uh then we are uh
challenged particularly if
the likelihood of something very good or
very bad happening is
is small and we have to kind of figure
out well you know
how do we how do we deal with this is it
a risk that we're willing to take and
that it's uh
beneficial for us to take
yeah i mean maybe to think through an
example lots of people are afraid of
flying on commercial aircraft and
there's all sorts of different
statistics that are often presented by
those who extol the safety record of
commercial
aircraft and sometimes they say here's
your risk of death per million passenger
miles flown or the chance of a fatal
crash is you know some small number and
you know if you told me there was a one
percent chance of a fatal crash i'm not
getting on the airplane i know that
that's quite high i've taken hundreds of
flights right so one out of a hundred
sounds very high but when the numbers
are smaller it does become more
difficult to think of what that really
means for us doesn't it
uh absolutely
and
uh more generally the the numbers really
don't communicate very well with us
what's more important is our is our
experience you know and have we
flown and everything's gone okay and
and what do we hear on uh on television
or media you know has it been a recent
crash or has been has there been
something that's happened that leads us
to have less trust in the safety of of
airliners like if there's a
like the 737s a few years ago
were mysteriously crashing and and
people didn't know exactly what was
going on well that was scary uh so
so all these things are are
a factor
that affects our what we call our
feeling of risk because most of the time
we we take uh risks depending on how we
how we feel about it whether whether
we're worried or scared as opposed to uh
whether the statistics uh you know
seem okay to us yeah i mean thinking of
the airplane example
you often hear you're more likely to get
into an accident and die driving to the
airport than on the plane but it
certainly doesn't feel that way i think
to lots of people so that seems to be
the psychological uh layer to it
right so there's a lot of things going
on there when you're when you're driving
you feel you know you're in control
of the risk and you are partially in
control although not as much as you
think you are because there are other
drivers on the roads and there may be
some bad uh conditions on on the roadway
and so forth but you feel in control
when you're on the plane you know that
you know you're not controlling that
plane and
so you have to trust
the pilots and the system uh these days
many of the planes are being flown uh um
you know by computer
but it doesn't you know we don't see
that
when it comes to something like covet 19
there's been a lot of interesting
websites where
you can plug in a variety of different
data about yourself and about a scenario
in which you're thinking of putting
yourself and the idea is it will spit
something out to you
uh objective that you can then use to
determine whether it's a safe enough
situation for you or not so of course we
know age and pre-existing conditions are
risk factors for getting very sick with
covered we also know that it spreads
more easily indoors than outdoors and i
did one of these before our interview
and i can keep feeding information right
how many people am i going to be around
are they vaccinated am i indoors or
outdoors will the encounter be one two
or three hours all these different
things and then it tells me your risk is
a three out of ten it seems like it's
very difficult to really turn that into
actionable uh intelligence in a sense i
mean it's so detailed but at the same
time what do i do with that information
uh absolutely first i'm not sure how
many people use use these sites yeah uh
most of the time we're just uh operating
again on on our experience and
and uh you know how much how important
it is for us to do you know to have this
meeting or to to go to this event and
this sort of thing and and again we're
using we're using our feelings uh more
than any statistic sure we know that in
general if we're older uh or we have a
pre-existing condition that makes us
vulnerable that we have to be more
careful and i think people are sensitive
to that and are trying to monitor that
and and and be careful but i think uh
more generally we as we see you know
very few people are taking uh
precautions right now we see a few
people wearing masks and
it's like it's like it doesn't exist
anymore even though covet is still still
uh quite uh prevalent uh you know we're
told that the uh the effects are not as
serious as the early versions and and we
feel pretty comfortable
going about our business as though
things were normal even though they're
not but again it's not really a matter
of statistics it's a matter of of how we
feel about it and the the thing about
our feelings is
sometimes uh they they deceive us
you know we can't always trust them
yeah the interesting thing about the the
back to normal covid feelings that you
talk about you know i don't remember if
it's daniel dennett or daniel kahneman
who had a particular heuristic that they
they wrote about
but there's this kind of familiarity
where once covet is no longer something
new and we've been living with the risk
for a period of time even if we have not
necessarily been actually engaging in
risky behavior ourselves it sort of
becomes background in a sense where this
is now part of the status quo of life
and it seems that may allow people to
feel as though the risk has lessened
even though it really hasn't maybe we've
just gotten more used to it
yes that uh that definitely happens so
um we're pretty comfortable with the
seasonal flu that you know
and
even though it could be serious a lot of
people got pretty sick and some died you
know it was something that we uh we we
lived it with and became kind of uh
normalized so these things become
normalized unless something special
happens just like gun violence i mean
gun violence in this country
has
become normalized but every once in a
while we have some sort of unusual and
horrific event like we have in recent
weeks in highland park illinois and
buffalo that shakes us out of that and
says wait a minute you know this is
different and we start to pay attention
for a while uh and then uh and then it's
sort of uh our concern uh fades away
there's sort of a window of uh when
we're suddenly awake to the problem and
concerned about it wants something done
and then uh
and then over time uh that window starts
to to close so
so again this is the way our our
feelings uh go you know that
that these events can shake us out of
our what we call our psychic numbing at
least for a while and that's the window
when action needs to be taken it seems
also there's the other side where for
example after 9 11
people's perception of the risk of for
example being on a hijacked plane or
being the victim of a terrorist attack
was also much higher than the real risk
as well
uh yes
and
you know what we know is that
that if the consequences are very you
know imaginable and scary you know again
that that creates a
just thinking about those consequences
uh sends a strong feeling of worry or
anxiety you know through into our brain
and then um
then it doesn't really matter what the
probability is that is that is our brain
can't can't moderate a feeling by a
probability unless you unless that
probability is so low that you could
call it zero right zero you don't worry
about it but as long as you've got that
feeling that's driven by the
consequences
you
it feels as though it's likely
and it doesn't matter whether it's a one
percent chance or a ten or a forty
percent those numbers don't matter
because you're thinking of the
consequences and you're feeling at risk
and we we call that you know probability
neglect you know that
that we're not sensitive to to the
different levels of probability
probability even though those are
important you know it really makes a
difference if the chance is one in a
million or or or one in ten one you know
this sort of thing it but but it's hard
for us when we're going on our feelings
to make those distinctions we need to
think uh analytically and and and step
away from our feelings and think about
well what is this probability you know
and is
and and how likely is it and what's it
compared to other probabilities
that we
that we encounter and know something
about so it's a very complicated dance
that our brain does between feelings and
reason
a couple other things i want to ask
about you mentioned this psychic numbing
uh one of the things that you have
worked on and elaborated is this idea of
the psychophysical numbing the idea that
if people hear about a lot a level of
loss of life for example that's an
extraordinarily large number
that it actually becomes more difficult
to connect to it with connect to it on
an emotional level and one of the things
i've talked about from a media analysis
standpoint is that one of the reasons
why a shooting with three victims gets
more media attention than death from
hunger in africa is that the story has a
defined beginning middle and end and
that makes it good for corporate media
but there's a whole other aspect to this
that relates to your work which is to
some degree if you hear 7 000 children a
day or dying from hunger that it's we
intuit that it's an extremely high
number but we're not necessarily
connecting to it
uh empirically in the way that we do to
the three shooting deaths to some degree
is that roughly what you have found
uh yes uh we we uh we we have a a saying
that that summarizes both what we've
found in laboratory research and what we
know from looking outside our window at
what's going on and that is that the
more who die the less we care it's a
rather uh startling uh
realization and that is you know that
that that we we care a lot about
individual lives and we'll do a lot to
rescue someone to protect uh an
individual particularly if we're if we
if we know their name uh know them
personally know their names see their
face and so forth you get an emotional
connection to that that life and it's
very important to protect you don't get
that emotional connection to the
statistics right you know
someone once said uh statistics are
human beings with the tears dried off
you know and
and so you have to you have to to work
at it to think about the individual
lives beneath the surface of those
statistics
yeah one of the things that some of
these charities that work on hunger in
africa have done is they tell you that
when you make a contribution you'll get
pictures and information about the
specific person that's being helped by
your donation whether it's true or not
it seems that they're working on the
idea that you're talking about here
uh yes they they recognize that as do uh
reporters who often you know try to you
know humanize the story by talking about
individual victims in a larger
tragedy like the school shootings you
know they you see up close and personal
something about the the individual lives
and and that uh that does uh that does
make a difference
last thing i i'd like to ask you about
you've done work on the um i believe
it's called the psychometric paradigm of
risk perception which relates to
if we have positive or negative feelings
about a certain activity
it affects our perception of how risky
it is so if for example you really like
motorcyc be riding a motorcycle you
might perceive that it is more safe
actually to ride a motorcycle than it is
in reality can you talk a little bit
about that
yes that again results from our relying
on our feelings as opposed to uh
statistics
so if if uh if if you like something you
have a positive feeling towards it
then
then it feels safer you know it feels
like the it's very beneficial and the
the risk is low if you dislike something
then you're likely to view it as high in
risk and low in benefit regardless of
what the statistics say
so for example with regard to uh to
medicines
or i'm sorry with regard to chemicals
there are chemicals we we
tend to think are good chemicals like
medicines and bad chemicals like
pesticides right so we rate pesticides
we start with our feeling that we
dislike them and so we judge them as
high in risk and low in benefit even
though pesticides have a lot of benefits
the same thing with with medicines
we we tend to have more favorable view
of medicines so we judge them as very
beneficial and low in risk even though
some medicines can be very dangerous so
we so it starts with our feelings and
then we derive our sense of risk and
benefit from those feelings
what's the right way to assess risk if
there is such a sense i mean do we need
experts are expert assessments
better than laypersons or how can we
sort of account for all of these biases
um
the right way is to
is to
try to
learn when we can trust our feelings and
when we when we can't and we just
discuss
the situation we can't trust our
feelings is when the number let's say we
get statistics that are large right and
complex the other is we we need to we
need to rely on experts you know
absolutely we we need to to kind of uh
but we also need to uh to evaluate what
we're hearing you know with our feelings
does you know does does does it what the
person is saying does it feel right is
there are there sources are there data
you know does that seem uh valid and so
forth we need both of these ways of
thinking uh what kahneman calls fast
thinking you know with our gut feelings
and slow thinking with you know analysis
and trust in experts uh we need to do
that we have need to we need to look up
for trusted experts to help us in these
complex situations
we've been speaking with dr paul slovik
who's a professor of psychology at the
university of oregon really appreciate
your insights and your time today
thank you very much
david follow us on social media interact
with the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's debunk some nonsense
claims that are spreading always
important if you're going to engage with
this stuff to at least have some sense
of what reality is and understand where
the the talking points come from now one
of the things that i have said before is
that very often the completely incorrect
wild destructive
uh conspiracy theories
um
from the right
have like a kernel of truth in their
origins now i don't mean that the
conspiracy theory itself has an element
of truth but what i mean is
what catalyzed the conspiracy theory is
something that is true that's like very
generally in the universe of what
they're talking about and we're going to
look at a clip here of lara logan lara
logan used to sort of be a respectable
journalist she has gone completely off
the rails we've covered some of her
anti-semitic stuff we've covered all of
her different conspiracy theories she
seems completely disconnected from
reality and she spoke somewhere you know
who the hell cares it's another there's
this circle the speaking tour circle
where
the crazier you the crazier the things
are that you have to say
the more likely it is that you'll get
more of these gigs and lara logan
claimed that illegal immigrants who
cross the border illegally get a social
security number at the border and that
then they can just go and vote now none
of that is true
i will tell you after we look at the
clip what is the likely origin of this
all right let's take a look questions
because it's quite satisfying having all
the answers
however
they they said they could not make a
decision at this time or they would let
me know
um that's true but they asked me two
very interesting questions when i went
there
they asked me if i'd be willing to take
up arms to defend the constitution of
the united states of america
isn't that interesting
they seem to have forgotten that part
right
um and then
you know among the many uh interesting
parts of this
is as you look around you
and uh
you know what you have to remember is
that they don't actually believe in
citizenship oh
and now when people come across the
board illegally and have this confirmed
from border patrol agents who are
actually physically doing this they get
given a social security number they get
given one
they get given that's
and interesting in the crowd go right
right
why would they get a social security
number that doesn't make any sense but
the crowd just right
right they get assigned a social
security number when they cross
i'm not sure how many of you are aware
of that and if you really want well the
people aware of it are wrongly aware of
it because it's not true and we'll get
to that you know when the cheating
starts it's long before you get to the
polls right
i mean think about it it starts with the
census
starts with counting illegal immigrants
in the census
how do you determine how many members of
congress you get
population times right
so how does you know california has all
these delegates at the at the electoral
college
and now of course the reason california
has all those um electoral votes
is california's population is genuinely
massive it's bigger than like most
countries
um but also the larger your population
at least in some general sense the the
larger number of undocumented immigrants
that might also be there don't just get
more money from the federal government
for your increased population you don't
just get more congressional candidates
representing you but what else do you
get you get an opportunity to pad the
voter rolls
with people but wait lara
undocumented immigrants can't vote
who are being completely and utterly
exploited
and there's one thing that i've that
i've learned as i've been investigating
this is they love euphemisms right
they love euphemisms sort of like
republicans right i mean they love to
say pro-life which really is a euphemism
for
uh we tell women what to do
it's all about democracy and if there's
any form of voter security that's voter
suppression and racism and white
supremacy and if it's the other side you
know anything we can do to get more
people out to vote but actually when you
when you talk to the canvassers they'll
tell you that when they go into the
low-income areas
you know sometimes they're predominantly
hispanic sometimes they're black
sometimes they're white but that's where
they find the most fraud
fraud that all the fraud is in those
areas now it may not shock you
that just about everything she's saying
is completely made up first of all as
far as frode or the freud or fraud or
whatever
um
it's really
it's almost non-existent
and the couple dozen cases that we've
actually identified since 2020 it's
almost all republicans it's like white
republicans in white republican areas
either testing the system or like one
guy voted for his wife who disappeared
we covered that last week but most
importantly the stuff about
undocumented immigrants are getting
social security numbers at the border
which then allows them to vote aaron
reichlen melnick
explained the truth about this on
twitter aaron's the policy director for
the american immigration council and
used to be an immigration lawyer
some asylum seekers wrote he wrote
become eligible for a work authorization
while they wait now it usually takes
about a year it's not happening at the
border but there are people who are in
the u.s illegally they've been in the
u.s for a year they've asked for asylum
they then get a work authorization and
they can get what's called the
restricted social security number it's
so that they can pay taxes
and legally work and listen to this
they pay into social security they're
not eligible to collect unless they win
asylum and become citizens so there are
some undocumented immigrants who after a
year
while waiting for their asylum request
to be adjudicated
have asked for work authorization have
been told you can do it but you've got
to pay into social security and if your
asylum request is rejected and you get
sent back to your source country
you don't get anything out of the social
security system essentially subsidizing
the social security payments of people
who will ultimately get benefits that's
the truth they're not eligible to vote
they can't register to vote they would
not be able to vote they don't vote they
can't vote
so
that's the
kernel from which some of these
conspiracy theories
originate
asylum seekers
can sometimes
eventually get a restricted social
security number and that becomes at the
border you just show up
and they give you a social security
number and next thing you know you're
voting for biden a complete and total
farce does lara logan know that she's
lying
i think she probably does
on this particular one i think that she
probably does let me know what you think
lauren bober radical republican
congresswoman lauren bobert
has shifted from the relentless attacks
on electric vehicles
to attempt to limit access to certain
types of firearms now there's a lot of
this sky is falling stuff from the right
on electric vehicles we heard yesterday
from marjory taylor green if everybody
gets an electric vehicle it's going to
be a dystopia
and there's not going to be any power
there's going to be blackouts people
will die there will be no food it'll be
crazy and we debunk that piece by piece
yesterday
lauren beaubert her sort of comrade in
arms as we might call it even though i
don't know that they really like each
other that much despite whatever they
might want to believe they are quite
similar in many ways she's going after
gun bans and lauren bobert said
yesterday that if you ban assault
weapons not even if you ban all guns if
you ban assault weapons and people still
can have handguns people are going to
end up eating dogs here in the united
states
what
listen living her life providing a crust
for your employees providing for your
family why did you do what you did in a
public forum in front of that politician
why did you feel the need to stand up
yes so dr gorka my upbringing i lived
under failed policies i lived in a
democrat household and i saw firsthand i
expected the policies of her own parents
in that democrat household
where her parents distributed food to
all the kids even though the kids
weren't working she was living under
democratic socialism in her own home
okay it's firsthand how restrictive
their policies are there's not a lot of
liberty uh under democrat rule in fact
it left us in uh breadlines waiting for
government cheese and i knew that that
was not america's best they give out
cheese in the bread line can you believe
that that sounds unorganized 11 years
old so i started working as a young
teenager at a mcdonald's and learned
that i could do a better job taking care
of myself than government did now fast
forward my i have a husband four
wonderful boys and a restaurant and a
lot of employees vendors patrons yeah
the restaurant has closed that i needed
to take care of and i saw the second
amendment um to be the best line of
defense to make sure everyone was kept
safe in my establishment now i am a
petite woman and i need an equalizer i
need an equalizer to protect me against
a larger potential aggressor and when
beta o'rourke told the world the
democrat playbook hell yes we intend to
take your ar-15s and your ak-47s i was
compelled to go to him because i saw
that a disarmed populist if the
citizenry in america is disarmed then we
are no longer citizens we are subjects
you know here in america we have gourmet
treats for puppies we have these amazing
groomers for dogs well in venezuela they
eat the dogs and it started because they
don't have firearms they do not have a
way to protect themselves to defend
themselves against a tyrannical
government now a great way to test this
hypothesis
no assault weapons
leads to eating dogs would be to look at
the countries around the world where you
can't get assault weapons and
they're really not eating dogs in any of
those countries now i know that there
are
a few countries where dog meat is eaten
and we've talked about some of those
countries before and those countries
have a sort of varying gun legislation
but by and large i i looked
there is no correlation between dog
eating and bans on all weapons guns
never mind specifically assault weapons
this is yet another one of these scare
tactics they don't know what to do next
it's but it's gotten to a point with the
gun stuff
where
the country is ready to say
let's try doing something with the guns
now not everybody and certainly not our
elected officials but at this point most
people don't think the issue is just
mental health most people don't think
the issue is just doors or ladders or
staircases or fire escapes or whatever
else
at some point
many people are going to say i don't
love it necessarily but let's at least
try dealing with the guns they may they
being republicans they may lose the
midterms because of their unwillingness
to do anything as far as the guns go and
so now they're coming up with you know
if we ban the guns you're going to be
eating you're going to be eating sparky
sparky's going to be barbecued if we get
rid of guns and of course it's absurd
and they're desperate to prevent
anything being done about the guns now
will anything be done about the guns
remains to be seen
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller asking about
could there be a millennial exodus
coming listen to this
hey david
so do you think it's reasonable to say
that
maybe in the next few years maybe up to
10 years we could experience some sort
of exodus
of young people say you know
um let's say 1920 to
19 or 20 years old so maybe early 30s uh
like young professionals who just feel
described by the way i don't think a 19
year old now is a millennial but that
doesn't even matter it doesn't even
matter we're still taking the question
bridged
um due to politics in this country
so many issues going on uh and they may
want to just live somewhere else um do
you think that that's really going to be
a possible thing and what do you think
most of the those young people would go
also for the
previous caller um
uh einstein bagels that's that's the
place to go
okay i don't know about the einstein
bagels thing so
here's the deal
um
there is no question
that there are
young millennials and then you know the
next generation after that i guess
that's gen z
who are very displeased
generally speaking with the
stagnant wage
student loan debt
right wing politics industrial complex
they're not feeling good about it and
many of them
would love to opt out in different ways
now opting out might be
accepting a sort of more simple rural
life rather than the typical graduate
from college and then move to or stay in
a big city that might be one element of
it
but the reality is most people are going
to need to work
and it's pretty difficult to move to
most other countries that people would
want to go to i mean some of the easier
countries to move to
are countries that are not necessarily
high on the list of places people want
to move to i mean there are there are
countries listen argentina where i was
born
it's relatively easy to move to
argentina and eventually find legal
status you can go if you eventually are
able to get employment or start
attending school
you are given a path to legalization it
takes years but you can just sort of do
it but the economy is a shambles and so
why would why would anybody want to do
it doesn't really make any sense
um so while i think the idea is is a
accurate one there's lots of people
young millennials gen z who would love
to say i'm packing it up i'm going to do
something completely different
unless you want to you know teach
english somewhere or join the peace
corps
sometimes these are the ways to do it
it's pretty hard to move to a lot of the
places people would want to to move to
and so for that particular reason i
don't think it's going to be a big thing
we have a great bonus show for you today
the senate republicans are now
backtracking after a huge firestorm over
the veterans bill
eastern kentucky flooding has now
caused
37 deaths and there is more rain in the
forecast what is going on what is the
infrastructure situation that is leading
to these deaths and also we have learned
that the sandy hook parents who are the
plaintiffs in the alex jones defamation
case due to safety concerns
they have been isolated with security
during this wacky alex jones trial all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com
to get instant access